i i believe it this time dave i promise
i think that i i really do i'm gonna you
know
i'm gonna know that's all i wanted you
to have to do all this other [ __ ] like
yeah so we're gonna do this handcuff
thing
i really kind of wanna do i think i
honestly think it's gonna be a hit i
will never
i will laugh for the rest of my life if
you guys actually do that it's going to
be
very inconvenient though i feel like
there's going to be a lot of assaultive
things happening
first of all i [ __ ] five times a day you
wouldn't have to go to the bathroom
you think i'm stupid no you think i'm
stupid
no what what what the [ __ ] is that do
you think i'm stupid
kind of i i actually kind of think you
are yeah yeah
i kind of think you are dumb first of
all thanks for your honesty
i listened to your show yeah i've heard
you on this show
over the years how long's the show been
out for six almost for six years yeah
your star [ __ ] attitude you pitch
this handcuff thing
to anyone that comes on the show it's
not special to me
you go oh hey i came up with this idea
you offer it to every [ __ ] person
that's been on you know what i think i'm
speaking
do you think i'm dumb i think you know
what i you know these are things
if if stupid [ __ ] thing i if stephen
yoon came in right now you wouldn't
offer that to him no i wouldn't [ __ ] it
out for that dude
these are things that you you don't say
out loud man you say it on the side like
it hurts my feelings george cut this
part out why
you just said i shouldn't say it out
loud no we're keeping it in we're not
cutting anything george erase that from
your [ __ ] log
all right let me say something right now
don't tell george what to do
i didn't tell george what to do okay
thanks for doing it though bud
really good to see you you're ending it
now no i'm not editing it
can i tell you how i picture this setup
what
slept king i don't know what's the
accurate number of hours you play video
games a day
right now three or four hours
oh collateral space no three or four
hours skyrim
yeah that's not true babe yeah all right
whatever it's
hours right yeah it's couple hours and
um
you probably i don't know the visual i
had and and don't
is that you're like hannibal lecter and
you're just like
porn jerking off video games coffee
cigarettes whatever
and then kaleido like wheels you into
the podcast room yeah
i don't know if there's a clock behind
me but it's like literally yeah that's
not you know
let me let me finish like why is this
podcast end after an hour
why is the only bit uh unhelpful advice
like like you you could be bigger than
joe rogan
you could be bigger than like you could
have the biggest [ __ ] podcast
and it's just like just [ __ ] like
dial it in like let's just do the least
amount of work
let's do the least amount of work
like you could turn this into a [ __ ]
huge show yeah
oh dave come on the 300 what i'm sorry
i'm sorry i'm sorry bro
this isn't my only dream dog
so what's your dream in hungary your
dreams came true in hungary
no but your dreams came true and hungry
it did kinda what happened in hungary
i did a movie so that's your dream right
i i'm doing a bunch of [ __ ] i sold a
sheet tv show i do this
i do stand up you know what i mean i i
do two podcasts
right resolution i don't want with
andrew santino as well that's doing very
well thank you george
right my point is is that i've got a lot
of balls in the
in the fight i haven't been looking at
george while i've been i got a lot of
balls
exactly as as i'm telling you this [ __ ]
i just see his head going like
this i see gilbert over there yeah they
know it's true what
like that in my whole life of knowing
you i gotta get on this
single camera stick calm i gotta i gotta
be on this movie you've been on movies
with the biggest movie stars on the
planet
you have been on sitcoms you do like i
just wanna do
my own my dream is as a st when i first
signed up
for op for open mic yes back
when i was 23 years old was i just
remember going sending my name and going
you know i want to do it all i want to
try it all i want to do stand up i want
to act
maybe if i can do radio that'd be cool i
want to do animation and i've done all
of it and i still do all of it
and nothing's going to stop me because
my dream it's all
encompassing all of it which one of all
and i'll be here to say you did you have
done all those things which one of those
things makes you the happiest
doing the two podcasts right and also i
like acting
and then stand up next so stand-up's the
least
stand up for me is something that i'll
always do right i did it last night for
the first time in over a year which went
really
well it was so fun and i did it with um
new material yeah i did four new jokes
that um wow
it was fun and then no and i um
it was writing he hasn't written yeah
yeah so it was fun
and i'm gonna do listen dude i'm gonna
you guys gonna be offended if i ordered
postmates to the house
no i thought we're i didn't know if
you'd have food here so
there's certain things that don't
deliver to my house so i i checked here
and i ordered i got
i got some for you i know what you mean
you're right what did you order already
he's here right now can i get it
yeah okay you keep talking all right
what is it
oh my god when'd you order it before the
podcast i'll tell them some
i'll tell them someone's coming out okay
yeah i ordered it right when i was
pulling in i i just
um oh my brother said yeah you want he
wants to eat
okay let's eat but you brought you just
got food
whatever we'll we'll take it